oh man
look at that heavy repeating blaster
get back in it
now we're getting more more gun play
from the mandalorians
oh the armorer's back handing off the
hammer i love how they just dropped from
this drop ship and the armor clubbing
in the head with a hammer
it's not just for making tools
baboo frick back in the house yes but a
bunch of fricks house of fricks house of
bricks what the freak what's the star
destroyer being built
i'm loving this season's gonna be sick
oh my god
uh uh it looks like a polish masa type
base on an asteroid field it's his uh oh
is that in the blue starfighter
well it is his booster it's been modded
right right right right right
oh my gosh but now he's got another
astromech droid back there as baby baby
groger just sits in the cockpit with
papa my bad
baby
why would you go back there
what awaits oh sabers up boys and girls
and non-binaries sabers up for everyone
welcome back to new rock stars the
mandalorian season 3 is confirmed to
return to the ruins of sundari the
mandalorian capital city that we saw
bombed in the book of boba fett
flashback uh yeah tommy and i were
reacting to some footage there but it's
not official footage that was released
but you know if you look hard enough you
can you can find it yourself we don't
encourage it uh here at new rockstars
but you know we've seen it i think if
you're watching this right now you've
seen it yourself let's not kid ourselves
um but here on the planet of mandalore
we know the living waters of mandalore
await dinjarin and the armorer is
obviously going to play a much bigger
role in this coming season we're going
to learn more about bo katan and her
failed leadership of the mandalorian
people this uh this
horribly tragic moment where rebels ends
with her holding up the dark saver we
had our hearts were filled with hope and
then we catch up with her in live action
she's like um uh yeah that gap on my
resume was um because i was just finding
myself or that's right that was her that
was her equivalent of the uh wonderful
2011 meme awkward
you were keeping that meme alive yes
awkward
but like we want to know why she lost
the dark save what really went down and
it seems like there is a reason that
will be explored in season three of the
mandalorian so is the armorer right are
the mandalorians cursed how far back
does this curse go is it a stain that
started with a splash of tar
this law
thank ferrari
i forced it i forced it i loved it
well i love you tommy this is wikileaks
you thought you thought we skipped a
week didn't you but no this is our
reaction show to the latest in star wars
and i'm here with tommy beck told yeah
tommy b hi
just what you thought we were going to
be
galactic no shows tommy and eric are
back to stunt on these hoes with all of
the greatest star wars theorizing we
don't need no stinking show we don't
need an episode drop we don't need to
react to something that just came out we
can talk star wars 24 7 52
365. that's you know what that's all i
want to talk about it doesn't matter if
uh you know elseworld in the world of
nerd you have things like you know
mutants existing in the mcu or or love
and thunder establishing that afterlives
are a thing i caught mephisto
i found him i found him he's in sunday's
video no time for that uh
westworld is on tv uh we we have a
marvel vfx artist in revolt uh our
marvel fans jumping the ship right now
well if you are jump right on to the ss
tommy and eric because we're talking
star wars right now a universe whose
cinematic future is in the hands of oh
wait god damn it taika with tt we can't
get away from this guy
and this because the show's called
wookie leaks don't worry about the ship
we're airtight
uh loose lips sink some ships but not
this one um snitches get kisses in our
universe
our lips are nothing but loose
already
skewing right off the rails in the
opening minutes
what are rails we don't know ships don't
abide by roads we're annoying we don't
need roads that's right uh we never had
them uh but here this week tommy and i
are gonna discuss the history of the
mandalorian people and why bo katan
really failed is there a curse the
mandalorian people and how correct is
the armorer to be such a superstitious
cultist uh before we uh talk about all
that just a reminder to go to new
rockstarsmerch.com to check out all of
our great merch options you know we got
a ms marvel inspired one cosmic daydream
now that this show established mutants
in them so you don't you want to mark
that historic occasion with a cosmic
daydream shirt you can also get our thor
inspired lace obsession uh worthy of
love because you are uh you might be i
think we all are worthy of love some of
you aren't um the uh 300 of you who
quote tweeted my uh inhumans versus
mutants tweet with some very vile things
about my loose lips in terms of kevin
feige's anatomy oh my god you may not be
worthy of love no you may have proved
this goat go frick yourself
do you think i won't you think i won't
find out where you all live i'm on the
dark web i've got tracers everywhere my
birds are everywhere i'm the lord varies
complete with no balls i got nothing
better to do than find all of you and
hurt you
tommy when they go when they go low we
go high republic now they served us well
in past elections like sure sure
we fight fire with hugs and then we get
burned alive when we do so and
we don't regret it hey tommy what are we
talking about this week
we're going to talk about something i
also uh sorry real quick you need to
plug that the break room is on tick tock
now follow us at the underscore break
room where we will be doing uh three to
four videos a day as the algorithm
demands hopefully today's only two
because i just started the channel today
and that's right i started the channel
i'm in charge of our tic toc break room
channel so if you have stuff you want to
see
get at me i'm going to be interviewing
all of our personalities on the break
room and hopefully getting people like
eric friends of the break room that we
treasure so much to send me in some of
their uh their tick tock thoughts as
well anyway getting on with the show as
is important to me eric
are those mandalorians cursed
are they cursed well tommy i mean i feel
like uh i'm cursed with
uh enthusiasm for this new tick tock yes
i try to go on to tick tock right now
but my phone auto paired to my
headphones causing the audio for my
computer screen that's recording our
connection software probably to play
through the microphone and really
confuse our editor hopefully we can
decide around that um but i will check
out that tick tock later can't wait to
see it um this question of the
mandalorian curse really came back uh to
the character of the armor remember back
at the beginning of this year when the
book of boba fett was really just a
shell a
russian nesting doll of a show really
just to house another two episodes of
the mandalorian and adventures of luke
skywalker um but i cannot i am obsessed
with re-watching this moment with the
armorer
and she's talking about the darksaber
and she said quote it is said one
warrior will defeat 20 and the
multitudes will fall before it if
however it is not one in combat and
falls into the hands of the undeserving
it will be a curse unto the nation
mandalore will be laid to waste and its
people scattered to the four winds
we have no idea what the four winds are
but i love it i love it when tv shows
and movies we talk about go into this
weird
made-up mythology
quoting uh scripture that we're just
kind of picking up pieces of i love it
it doesn't seem like usually violent
fanatical
uh
ideologies
like their excuse for when they don't go
right is we're cursed we were cursed
it's not that it's not that our fascism
didn't work it was cursing we got cursed
[Music]
that's why you've got to vote this year
reverse the current house just keep
voting just keep voting and if it
doesn't just keep on voting can't curse
a vote
[Laughter]
you kind of did it with the cadence of
horoscope like can't curse the vote
it comes about i was voting
may not be a smart man but i know what a
curse is
just watched that movie recently
uh man that boomer porn holds up as much
as it can but there are problems with
that movie
yes there is a scene where
jenny and forrest
i don't think forrest can legally
consent in the scene touching and things
happen that poor roommate who had to be
a witness to it all
i mean that the slow pan down of the
roommate
back turn just like
okay i i miss this in the dozens of
times i've seen forrest gump horse goes
i ruined your roommate's bathrobe like
he gets it all in her bathroom yeah yeah
i've never heard that line before i turn
the kelly and i'm like did i never hear
that before she's like yeah you didn't
know that was that happened i was like
you know what i use i'm stunned because
i don't remember that part either
i think i blocked it out or as a young
man was so ashamed of my own bathrobes
i'd ruined anyway well i i think the tnt
edit leaves that part out yeah probably
cut up that scene yeah for sure um
anyway getting back to star wars this is
a star wars show i'm sorry that was my
fault um
i loved it the armor also mentions the
songs of beyond's past foretold the
mythosaur rising up to herald the new
age of mandalore sadly it only exists in
legends and then she starts to throw
some shade at bo katan she goes bo katan
it's a cautionary tale she once laid
claim to the rule of mandalore based
purely
on blood and the sword you now possess
but it was gifted to her not one by
creed bocaton crees was born of a mighty
house but they lost sight of the way her
rule ended in tragedy they lost the way
and we lost our world had our sect not
been cloistered on the moon of concordia
we would have not survived the great
purge those born of mandalore straight
away from the path eventually the
imperial interlopers destroyed all that
we knew and loved in the night of a
thousand tears only those that walked
the way escaped the curse prophesied by
the creed though our numbers were
scattered to the winds our adherence to
the way has preserved our legacy and the
generations until we may someday return
to our home world well mando we know in
season three will return to that home
world and uh
maybe stay away from it and the place
looks a little chernobyly to me it's a
bit of a mess
it's a fixer-wrapper uh i think that
that quote should have ended with i am
the armorer and i approve this message
this message was paid for by
uh mandalorian cultists
yep
bo katan only got the dark saber because
she had a famous family
i was thinking this would just play in
like a massive auditorium
where someone up is at a lecture and
it's just like to lrh and they all go
down arch and they just salute tara
visla or something to tv
the tv tv this is the way this is the
because we don't follow the way but the
way is there
i like the references to the way into
the winds as if like the winds are like
the the devilish spirit that will throw
you off of the way like there's this
weird uh metaphorical symbolic path that
you can walk and the winds can blow so
mightily dust in your eyes that you'll
stray off of that path so the winds the
four winds i'm dying to know what the
four winds are you know like uh i assume
that we'll learn more about these these
spiritual
entities uh we know of like you know the
uh uh uh the the mortis realm right the
whole mortise arc in clone wars but
those were that was almost like based on
christian theology of the father and the
son and the holy spirit he had the
father the son the daughter uh like that
there wasn't a number four there but
that was also like kind of a jedi uh
mythology that we're exploring there
force mythology the mandalorian
mythology is obviously a different
spiritual framework uh so i can't wait
to learn more of it but this idea of a
curse i think comes back from tarvislaw
i think uh tarvisla was really the one
who left this curse on the the dark
saber it like in much of legend weapons
often carry some kind of curse for the
blood that they've spilled and the
division they've caused and uh i think
in this case that's the kind of curse of
the mandalorian blade wheels that no one
is meant to wield it uh and you know
back when we still liked game of thrones
and it seemed to have some promises as a
series we talked about the iron throne
and i really like the idea that the iron
throne as uh thrown made of swords is
cursed and no one ever should sit on it
that as soon as that iron throne was
forged by the aegon the conqueror that
uh that's really a curse that left uh
westeros you know yeah or that was left
in westeros uh something that you know
i'd love to explore more in like house
of the dragon right that takes place uh
thousands or at least hundreds of years
after that um
so what i want to know uh about uh the
dark saber is what this curse is i think
tar visa as a mandalorian jedi um i
think the the curse that happened after
he died is that there would be this war
between the mandalorians and the jedi
that there was this uh perennial
division between these two groups of
people in star wars lore um and that the
only way that this curse will be
uh gone vanquished is by having
a uh descendant of tar easel and i think
that descendant is grogu i think grogu
is going to be the only other
mandalorian plus jedi
a fusion
and then uh so i think grogu is going to
be the destin wielder of the dark saber
and that uh curse will finally be broken
i love that
i hope that we explore this in the
acolyte
i'm super excited for the acolyte and
like i don't need any cameos in it but
just some of that lore yeah
like the jedi uh the cameos can be the
the the cameos can be the legends being
explained not led no pun intended but
like
rather than a character cameo perhaps
referential cameos of like this concept
that has been uttered in a line or
sentence in a previous star wars
property is now being fleshed out that
would be so satisfying i think um yeah i
i want like uh i love that we're hearing
about this curse from the perspective of
a cult that just happened to survive
that purge you know just because they
were on concordia at the time um but
like the way into a religion and the
fact that even religions have different
branches of them that the most uh
militant extreme
radical branch of that religion is the
one who is now uh preaching it and
speaking on behalf of all of them like
we are the survivors of it so listen to
us uh to me that is fascinating to me i
think it is the most interesting thing
about the mandalorian as a series
absolutely
absolutely
um so these living waters uh like i you
know when we watched boba fett together
tommy like yeah we we talked about the
the gaffy tree this crazy moment where
boba fett was walking through the desert
and we saw crashing waves and then it
was almost kind of like birth imagery uh
to me that was like the high water mark
of of the book of boafat the fact that
boba fett revealed uh you know or went
into at least a bit more how tattooing
used to be covered in oceans and that
the uh the tuscans like many of the
native creatures of the planet might
have been aquatic beings at some point
and that's why you see like whale
carcasses i think in the desert and
obi-wan it's like crate dragons might be
aquatic that's why uh biologically the
sarlacc has uh has etymological
connections to other squid beans that we
see on ner it's because tatooine needs
to be an ocean world i'm rambling here i
know but i'm just saying that like i
think that's what is most interesting
about star wars right now is uh
exploring more of like the the weird
sacred religious beliefs that these guys
yes and in the ancient and the in the
and the ancient uh topography of these
worlds that has changed now due to
interlopers and conquerors that have
destroyed with their spice mining and
their
obsession with trade and money
you know
and you you kind of are referencing the
fact that star wars is based so heavily
on frank herbert's dune and that's what
you know denny villeneuve and these new
and these dune films definitely has over
star wars is the fact that it does go
deep into uh into spirituality and and
supernatural phenomena as a religious
belief and how problematic that is and
how political it can get i mean i think
george lucas wanted to explore that with
the prequels uh but he really just kind
of explored a more secular approach to
to political uh drama and strife um
which is fine i think he was kind of
reflecting the world that the prequels
came out in which was you know the war
on terror the bush administration the
re-invasion of iraq and i think that's
what he wanted to reflect and looking
back you know i think he made some
interesting points um uh but i think he
did miss out on uh the way uh culture
wars were really happening the way it
was like christian fundamentalism in
america in the west trying to supplant
and oppress
um um like
islam and how much islamophobia was
really
uh coursing through the veins of
americans during that decade and still
to this day does uh and i think that's
what frank herbert had in mind when he
was writing dune
because he could see that that's where
things were headed in the mid 20th
century
that there was you know uh
the fact that all the wars being fought
between israel and egypt and uh
terrorism now rising up in the middle
east i think you could see that that was
a there was a an additional crusade that
was that was a bruin and how right he
was
uh so
to me that's i'm i'm honestly more
excited for the future of the dune
verse than i am for the star wars verse
i know that's psych religious stuff how
could you say that i just max rebo plug
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
isolate that for the tick tock
hey let's but let's restore our hope
right now tommy as we look ahead to star
wars i think uh likes like marvel right
now i think a lot of star wars fans
feel a little um lost in the desert uh
not sure what the the path is caught up
in those four winds um and i think uh uh
you know you know look i love taiwai tt
i will watch everything that he does but
coming out of thor live and thunder i
think there is a backlash to our man
taiko aditi which might just be the way
the things that irreverent things the
guy is saying in interviews this is
always
what tt has been i think a lot of it is
his kind of flippant attitude when he
does press that's more like it's
tongue-in-cheek you never really realize
i also think that he is
and i use the word audacity in my own
way tongue-in-cheek he has the audacity
to push buttons and like push boundaries
in his in these main
you know huge franchises i that i think
make some people uncomfortable and they
have some evolving in their own lives to
do before you know so they'll just you
know the backlash
most of the tyco backlash that i saw
almost entirely this is just my personal
experience originated on twitter where
backlashes tend to last 24 hours and
then we move on to having a backlash
against someone else and it usually
happens when someone is has like a 100
approval rating it's like someone's got
to come in and start planting the seeds
of like no but this but this but this
i didn't think thor love and thunder was
a perfect movie by any means and i
thought at times it was a little
uh a little bit like
it it was too heavy on the jokes and not
enough on the
on the on the the thornist but overall i
thought it was phenomenal i loved it and
i just think that
uh
i if you watch his two thor movies
and then any of his other work and think
that he wouldn't make a good star wars
movie i don't know what to tell you i'm
not sure like i think that that i think
he is fine i think the thing
that is making people feel lost in both
of these fan ships is we don't have
avengers to hang on to this is all
leading to avengers and we don't have
skywalker saga to hang on to this is all
leading to skywalker saga so if you are
a person
that needs to know where everything is
heading of course this is a frustrating
time but
i don't think i mean like you have to
remember at the end of the day these are
for-profit movie studios there is a plan
it is heading somewhere we just don't
know yet and what why not just enjoy the
ride why not just
enjoy these content as they come in plus
at the end of the day mandalorian season
three why star wars fans should have
hope christopher lloyd is showing up at
some point
that's all you got i mean like
christopher lloyd is going to be in the
star wars universe
goodbye that's all i need who do you
think is i think he's going to be some
like crazed mandalorian authors who's
living amongst those minds like he's got
a weird little like reverse
he's just like paddling through the
living waters like these waters aren't
safe for you
run for it
[Laughter]
he's gonna be great he did it
[Music]
i mean to me to me what gives me the
most hope is uh we're talking about
cameos i am okay if we never see like a
familiar cameo of something
for the next couple years in star wars i
think we're good i think we're good i i
think of all these titles tommy as much
as i'm excited for like a mandalorian
season three in ahsoka i think the
acolyte i think the acolyte is the title
on the on the horizon where i'm like yes
i cannot wait for that you and i were at
star wars celebration and one thing i
want to say about star wars fans is i
know when you just live your life on
twitter or on tick tock or on youtube
wherever you're at uh online it can feel
like
these fandoms are toxic and i get it
every fandom has a certain subset of
them that are just gonna be
really brutal and cruel and cynical but
being in anaheim amongst star wars fans
you don't you don't see any of that you
don't see any of that you just see a
loving group of nerds who are just
excited to take part in something just
want to talk about the things they like
it's not it's not a lot of hatred and
like there's no focusing on hating
things it's all like i'm really into
this i'm into droids i've been to
twilight's i'm into twilights i got a
lot of fiction twilight fiction the
pleasure gardens the pleasure spas i
love it but uh anyway
yeah yeah i know you i know you do
you got to bring me with you on one of
those yeah you know what i i just say
leave your wallet at home just bring
cash because if you go on credit those
twilights they'll get every last dime
from you
yeah that's what they do that's what
they did
um but i think like you know even when
you
meet these star wars fans in person
uh
they you know we don't
we can talk about things we didn't
really like but even that is done in
like a respectful way they're like you
know what like you'll hear people say
like prequels uh i didn't really dig the
prequels or i didn't really dig the
sequel trilogy um like you but you don't
ra if anyone were to say out loud like
erase the sequel trilogy from canon i
think you'd get a boo i think most
people would be like ah no
let's not do that like i think that is
like you don't you wouldn't hear a cheer
of a room like even if people kind of
also believe or agree that you know this
you could erase the sequel trilogy from
canon and that might be better for star
wars i i think people all kind of like
respect lucasfilm and respect these
artists too much to just like erase the
things that they added i mean
god damn it i can't believe that people
would want to erase some of the dialogue
from the last jedi i mean
i get that kanto bite subplot is weird
but it's just like i love what luke and
rey and yoda's force ghosts go through
in the last jedi i love it so much so i
would say what gives me hope for for
star wars are titles like the acolyte i
can't wait for that uh and uh and yeah
i yeah i would say and hold on to hope
hold on to hope baby hold on for one
more day
uh we'll leave it there for this episode
of wikileaks thank you so much for
joining us uh you can follow me at ea
boss follow tommy tommy bechtel follow
new rockstars subscribe to wikileaks
wherever you get your podcast we're
gonna try to keep up with the the
breaking star wars news as it comes out
this summer um obviously when endor
comes back we're gonna be covering that
a lot as a channel uh but for now we
just want to thank you so much for
joining us yes we have
spoken
you